partons maintenant à chinon la
forteresse royale pays de mille feux
depuis ce soir elle est illuminée et on
part tout de suite sorte place on
retrouve marielle schaeffer
administratrice du site bonsoir et merci
d'être en direct avec nous alors jusqu'à
quand pourra-t-on admirer sa lumière
abba désormais tous les jours donc on va
éteindre à 23 heures en hiver
et puis c'est une mise en lumière qui
qui peut se voir toute l'année et y
compris en saison jusqu'à une heure du
matin samedi
ça va rester au delà des fêtes de noël
oui ce n'est pas un projet qui est liée
uniquement aux fêtes de noël c'est un
projet global qui vise à modifier en
fait la mise en valeur de la forteresse
de manière pérenne alors quel est
l'intérêt pour vous c'est un atout
supplémentaire en terme de tourisme oui
tout à fait on a souhaité par ce projet
et avec les concepteurs lumière candela
et puis nocta bene donner une dimension
contemporaine et spectaculaire à la
forteresse et en ce sens on est déjà
bien aidé par la position du site en
hauteur est-ce qu'il a fallu du temps
imagine pour mettre en place tous ses
projecteurs et tous ces led
oui là on arrive au bout d'un chantier
qui a duré près de huit mois qui a
commencé les l'hiver dernier qui a fait
une pause estivale de manière à ce
qu'ils aient le moins de nuisances
possibles au niveau des travaux pour les
visiteurs du site les touristes et après
cette pause estivale le chantier a
repris depuis le mois de septembre
eh bien merci à vous d'avoir un gros
chantier en direct avec nous et ben un
chantier à avoir maintenant pour de vrai
à la forteresse royale de chinon merci à
vous